[Music]
hello
[Music]
you're so stupid they measured your iq
in celsius oh yeah well you're so fat
you should probably work for buzzfeed
boldly yeah well your mommy's such a
floozy she probably hashtag shouted her
abortion oh yeah well your dad's such a
transie that he should probably work for
fun hold on now wait a minute wait a
minute now don't bring nobody's
transgender father into this
z ain't here now remember
if it weren't for your transgender
father you wouldn't be here
so remember kids
if you make fun of one training you're
making fun of all chinese all around the
world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
father
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
father mother
i'll always love her
my father
so treats me right
right
t is for the transition father mother
dick
making me proud i'm his or her kid r is
for respect you better show the miss it
don't matter
she used to have a d
a is for the anger and pains and aches
that she went through to have his
hormones replaced
n is for the new vaginas he has
use the proper pronouns or seals spectra
another in here is for neutral bathrooms
that father mother needs when she drops
the deuce
the last letter why is that you better
show respect it's incredibly painful
trying to change your sex father
there is no other
like father
[Applause]
[Music]
right
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is
man you need to settle down find your
business okay
ma'am once again man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that is delicious oh that is
absolutely wonderful so it's a new uh i
got a new teeth you know i just recently
got back into the tea
because uh and this is true the reason i
stopped was because of how aggressive
they were at the mall from tavana
it was like carnival barkers it's like a
third world country where they're going
to haggle with you i guess they shut
down a while ago so the point is i
shouldn't let other people affect my
emotions that much i've also been tea
bagged at the mall yeah well look we're
going to be talking about that don't say
gay bill in just a little bit
and mark hamill
so before we get to well before we get
to anything else look today we are going
to be talking not only about russia
ukraine but of course about the media
reaction here uh surprise i don't know
if you know this trevor noah and joy
reid think that you are racist if you
care about
our ukrainian uh friends uh and we're
also going to be talking about how this
affects you when we're these new
sanctions
yeah also the idea of the united states
uh dollar being used as a reserve
currency there are a lot of elements
here that maybe people aren't really
taking into account we're not just world
war three doesn't necessarily look like
world war one and two
especially when you have international
governments who are beholden to each
other and linked you know this whole we
are the world thing kind of backfires
when you know you're only as you're only
as strong as your asshole-ish link
it's true
so uh speaking of which and after that
intro uh if uh you miss us here on
youtube and we haven't told you that
we're not doing a show on youtube it's
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
you can watch us on rumble nothing would
make me happier than youtube to crumble
under the weight of the rumble overlords
and of course uh mug club livestream mug
club 99 for students uh 99 or 69 for
students veterans active military we're
going to do another hour of the show uh
what's going on there tim the tool man
are you uh
are you okay i don't have overlays so uh
oh geez let's bring them in well
if we don't have them in you guys all
know references are all available
we'll get them we'll get them in two
minutes and my question of the day
before i bring her friends in how much
longer can joy reid remain employed uh
while her go-to is calling everything
racist
other than herself it's sort of like how
long could ronda rousey be champion you
know
once people figured out the armbar yeah
but that was it yeah well she had like a
bunch of setups sturdy doesn't even have
more setups she just goes straight to
your racist and i don't even say well
okay well we've already done that
so i don't know but again no one really
watches her all right before we move on
to that gerald how are you i am well sir
how are you i'm okay okay uh yeah i got
some sleep what yeah i got like for me i
can operate on six hours i'm like uh
elon musk well let me just so you know
tonight if you sleep a clown we'll eat
you yeah so you're gonna go to bed
thinking that now no that's why i have a
guard on my door i have like one of
those doorstops it's not going to help
yeah
well i figured it helps that i'm not six
so i'm i'm in a less at-risk category
there you go that's the problem with
being a six-year-old you're
at very little risk for kovid
huge risk for clown rape
yeah you know the good lord giveth the
good lord taketh away and you hear him
you see him you know him you love him
you can follow him on twitter at landau
dave dave landa how are you ahoy good
how about you well i'm okay but we're
going to uh get into stephen colbert
here oh cool and i know you're not a fan
no huge fan oh i saw him read up a
poetry at carnegie hall against trump it
was great yes
poetry or it was the worst thing i've
ever seen
you ever been to an open mic night and
see someone go up and do slam poetry ah
no imagine i leave it's sort of the
burlesque dancer of the comedy world
like the burlesque dancers or strippers
who couldn't make the cut slam poets are
comedians who couldn't make the cut yes
it was i went to see nathaniel reitliff
and uh jason isbell lead singer and the
lead singer of the black crows and now
came stephen colbert to do uh a poem
called the mockingbird oh uh i don't
know if you can see uh dave there you uh
you can pick up the names you dropped so
no
i didn't meet them oh i paid a ticket to
see them
at them
but if i did have that i wouldn't drop
them all the time i'd be like hey guys
you know who i've met
but uh yeah he came out and sang i saw i
was saying did a poem called the
mockingbird about trump oh yeah and it
was
even it was for
uh a thing to free to bed or whatever
crap i'm not sure where tibet stands but
something about tibet
and uh afterward they immediately banned
him every liberal in carnegie hall was
like oh like everyone was uncomfortable
with what he did i agree with what he
said but ah that was terrible president
no it wasn't i didn't agree with
anything no then he wrote up
the liberals people were like i should
have gone to the deli that's right you
went to the hall i think joy reed should
get into wrestling now that we know she
can take a fall yes
but only male wrestling yeah well it's a
gender bender with wrestling we don't
know anymore
so this is something that stephen
colbert said either yesterday or the day
before depending on when you're watching
this uh
or depending on my timeline i believe it
was the night before last yeah
one of those things i'm just trying to
soften the blow here it's a it's a
psychological term right they're using
it's like a front loading yeah it's
pretty bad and if you work to support a
family you're probably not going to be
thrilled and by that i mean you're going
to want to punch a hole through the
entire world here's stephen colbert
letting you know just how virtuous he is
in paying higher gas prices since the
invasion oil prices have skyrocketed
today the average gas price in america
hit an all-time record high of over four
dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
applause sign
yeah
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon he'll i'll pay 15
a gallon wrong because i drive a tesla
oh now
i mean the term tone deaf is thrown
around quite a bit but he just said to
an audience of largely middle-class
people who were sitting out in the
freezing cold waiting to get into that
studio that
i'll pay 15 a gallon because i drive
something you can't afford right i'm i
make 16 million dollars a year is that
what you said earlier it's fifth between
15 and 16. which just makes me mad yeah
don't worry it's disgusting but also
they're clapping because there's a sign
that tells them to because no one on
earth agrees with that yes yeah that's
the only sign people respect anymore i
guess that in the no smoking sign on
airplanes yeah i wonder what his jet
takes yeah exactly he has a tesla jet
dave oh that's true of course yeah no he
said i i'm willing to pay by the way
how's your tesla powered
not only is your i know he's in uh is he
in new york is it powered with the smell
of his own farts yeah i bet he'd love
that yeah he would yeah well the problem
is he wouldn't power his tesla because
he'd just be he'd use all the fuel yeah
that's true he's like ah i keep huffing
it it's your own brand no i'm pretty
best
let's take a take into power also think
about this people don't really we are
we are light years away from being if
everyone switched to tesla's tomorrow
and i think teslas are cool cars i like
tesla's right here in america i love
tesla's i did a whole segment with hodge
twins on tesla where i said my mind was
changed i was wrong about tesla's okay i
want to be clear about that but if
everyone switched to teslas or electric
cars tomorrow our power grid couldn't
handle it
well the owner of tesla doesn't agree
with him right
the guy who makes the stuff yeah exactly
you mean the evil oil baron from fern
gully elon musk yeah the terrible man
who invented the
uninvented but perfected the election
perfected the electorate and everybody
hated him for it yeah and then of course
they chastise him for smoking a joint on
joe rogan's show it's like yeah you're
pro pot in your pro-electric car and now
you're vilifying this guy this guy who
perfected the electric car had to leave
california for texas yeah well i think
the problem was he got rich
that's the issue oh he was successful ah
now we hate him even though he does
everything we like i was enjoying a
joint with the one guy that everyone
smokes a joint with this is horrible yes
i mean that guy smokes joints like
parliament's joe rogan yeah why wouldn't
they hit a joint that's the least
problematic thing that he puts in his
body joe rogan smoked so much weed
willie nelson would say i have to go
home now joe that guy hit a joint and
was like you know what i'm going to
space yes that's incredible
by the way here's the flame throwers
play around with it yeah
see what happens
good lord
colbert though is just completely out of
touch and the fact that any of his
audience would agree with this is absurd
well here's the thing he's saying the
quiet part out loud just so you know
this is a guy who gets on calls with
people in this administration this is
the guy who advertised four vaccines
right modernity this was a glorified ad
cloaked as a sketch and i know that
because we do glorified adds cloaked to
sketches
that being said there isn't the same
we're not getting them from big pharma
from built bar from you know
walther the dancing gas cans just lost
their jobs yes exactly
no no we need dancing colbert farts i
just
it's just batteries so much money so his
salary is more than the budget forever
this includes rent utilities salaries
for everyone yourself yours truly and he
still gets half the viewers in the
demographic that we do yeah well and he
also said something that not a lot of
people resonate with like i'll pay a
couple of extra dollars to have a clean
conscience i'm like oh really for gas do
you understand what gas does to the rest
of the prices in the market for the
people who can't afford to pay more for
food and for shelter and for insurance
all of that stuff starts to creep up it
starts to increase with inflation not to
mention your clean conscience doesn't
really mean anything when it would exist
if you filled up your tank with dead
babies right ouch no it's true
no my god my conscience is clean hey
what's your stance on abortion up until
birth and including shut up
well up until 14
apparently yeah i guess can we do a
trial period to see if you want to keep
him yeah that's where he stops though
and i wonder why can we do a trial
period for late night hosts
and believe me it's not look this is
less people say they did it to conan
right they did it they should still have
it now they rightfully did it to lily
sing well well yeah but this is the
whitest guy on television so i'm not
protecting my ilk just to be clear he
sucks yeah yeah we're totally i'm
totally anti-white when it comes to
stephen colbert yes i don't think he
should have incredibly white please
replace him with any black person you
can find as a matter of fact if you were
to replace him with the black comedian
doing the white guy voice
if i were to listen to it on audio i
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
right yeah i wanna replace him with
sinbad yeah send back doing the white
voice think about using i'm fine paying
an extra one or two bucks per gallon
what what would you say would you say
i'd be fine paying 15 because i drive a
tesla you really just
you haven't had your ass kicked in a
long time have you i say get chevy chase
or bill cosby yes yes one or the other
yeah the worst host of late night and
just a guy who's not very good
all right uh let's move on here now to
someone else who is on television
because that's a thing that's a
qualification by the way is brian
stelter still employed i don't know he
he thinks he's going to be fired because
cnn wants to apparently do news i'm
going to lose everything
36.
i want to do the pelosi
okay shane's his seatless bike up
outside of cnn
i don't want him to steal the seat
that's why i don't have one that's where
i meet don lemon to fight by the bike
racks you [ __ ] that was my spot
stealing all the good men i mean women
yes i know you took my banana seed i saw
you making eyes at cuomo
he's mine damn it
so uh of course joy reid echoed
something that trevor noah said earlier
this week and spoiler alert
ukraine russia really the not the issue
it's not the global economic policy it's
not the fallout it's not the potential
for world war three it's not the
instability it's not about us fighting
wars in which we have no actual vested
interests or potentially joining in or
basically fighting a war let's be honest
about it yeah uh we're just not we just
haven't dropped bombs yet no no all of
this according to joy reid and trevor
noah is about racism which brings us to
this week
insane in the ukraine
[Music]
now i know that it's ukraine not the
ukraine but the point is look just head
to work yeah as a juggalo
i have to be true
to cypress hill yes oh wait is it in the
membrane for some reason i don't know
that's right that's true
in the brain you know what a lot of
people think that kill a man is rage
against the machine but it's not it's
cyprus
and the better version of cyprus and i
like cypress hill all right so uh joy
reid made this statement on her show
that the only reason people care so much
about ukraine is because something
something racism as the world watches
the devastation unfolds in ukraine
nearly 4 000 miles away another crisis
is deepening that we don't hear much
about in the us and that is the war in
yemen the coverage of ukraine has
revealed a pretty radical disparity in
how human ukrainians look and feel to
western media compared to their browner
and blacker counterparts with some
reporters using very telling comparisons
in their analyses no that means accurate
this isn't a place with all due respect
um
you know like iraq or afghanistan that
has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully too
a city where you wouldn't expect that or
hope that it's going to happen
civilized okay let's face it the world
is paying attention because this is
happening in europe if this was
happening anywhere else would we see the
same outpouring of support and
compassion
but we don't need to ask ourselves if
the international response would be the
same if russia unleashed their horror on
a country that wasn't white and largely
christian okay a couple of things there
compassion do you mean like accepting
record numbers of refugees who went on
to commit mass rapings across europe
now we've paid attention to this for a
very long time it's just hard to pay
attention when of course uh
the wars over there never stop there's
never been peace in that region of the
world also it's inconsequential to the
rest of the world as a general rule what
do i mean by that
in case you think that's derogatory i
mean they don't matter as much
not their lives i mean their global
impact now this is not something unique
to joy reid so expect to see this
playbook just like yesterday when we
basically fact checked we like an oracle
biden in real time we fact checked him
before he said what he said
um trevor noah said this about ukraine
earlier this week here's the thing
people here's the thing beyond the
racism right like let's let's forget the
racism oh how i wish we could forget
about the racism shut up you do realize
that until very recently fighting crazy
wars was europe's thing that was
europe's entire thing it wasn't the item
of european history they even had
something called
the hundred years war you understand how
long that is that's like a decade wrong
there's one person they got a nobel
prize because they stopped fighting
imagine that
now people are going to be like oh to
see this in in europe to see this
like i'll tell you now i don't know
about you but i was shocked to see how
many reporters around the world by the
way seem to think that it's more of a
tragedy when white people have to flee
their countries because i guess what the
donkeys were built for it nope
okay couple things wow first off um
i guess there's peace in africa
you can't find a battle in africa you
can't find a war going on
nary a fight to be found in africa it's
a white people thing second let me be
really clear to joy reid and trevor noah
and you can comment below if you know
what i'm about to say i think it could
be said pretty quickly uh
in a short summary no the reason we're
talking about russia ukraine is because
it's the single biggest greatest largest
military action that's been take that's
taken place in europe since world war ii
you get it
contrast to the middle east
people are at war all the time
yeah it's people's it's people whose old
[ __ ] looks just like their new [ __ ]
fighting other people whose old [ __ ]
looks just like their new [ __ ]
well that reporter's point was look this
isn't a war-torn area this isn't
somebody who's been fighting wars off
and on forever with iraq and iran and in
yemen you have to understand that that's
mostly a civil war that's being
supported by two other countries it's
not like saudi arabia invaded yemen or
iran invaded yemen right they basically
are just supporting different sides of
the conflict in yemen yeah it's a
different thing it's still horrible
nobody is saying that that's fine right
what we're saying is russia is trying to
come in and take over another country
and take from them everything that they
have yeah these other kinds of countries
i don't know right there yeah yeah and
it's not because they're white and some
of these guys are could be because it's
one of our greatest uh greatest uh
adversaries
really in modern history for the united
states of america and the greatest or
largest i want to say greatest i want to
be careful the largest scale military
action that has taken place from one
country in europe against another since
world war ii just so happens to have
been committed by someone who we've had
to keep our eye on for a while exactly
and what is the domino's after this is
what a lot of people are worried about
too it's like okay what's next if he
takes ukraine is he going to go and do
some other stuff against the nato
country and now we have to get involved
what happens if iran let's say iran just
attacks yemen and takes it over
geopolitically what happens you're
overthinking nothing
i hate i think it really just comes down
to uh they are advocates for black on
black crime and i don't care for it yeah
no i know they are racist they're just
handing out handguns
it's literally two of the dumbest
statements i've ever heard and the white
guy who's there was like i don't know
how i can say this it's fairly european
it's like what has it meant it's people
running from their homes so they don't
die and you have a problem that they're
white i'm sorry right no he was trying
yeah he's just trying to say like yemen
is a is relatively um uh uh more um
civil like maybe european
ow now if you follow that up and go okay
what does he mean by that does that does
that mean that he's by the way how is it
racist for him to say that when he's
comparing it to other middle eastern
countries he's comparing it to what he
means is you know
plumbing
so yeah you do just small small things
yeah but good for her for being a
complete piece of [ __ ] yeah sorry
i just don't understand why anybody
would sit there and say this is about
racism yeah no it makes no sense it's
become the argument it's the only
argument they have and it's so boring at
this point and the only people who could
uh i guess
be perceived as not racist would have to
be people like me and people in this
room who don't think we should be
engaged in this war between russia and
ukraine at all so i mean we're not even
saying that we should go and save white
people
you're the only people at msnbc the
democrats the republicans the john
boltons of the world right the
establishment rhinos and the
establishment democrats those are the
racists were the is it done now are we a
nazi here
yeah we're not supporting white people i
don't think well yeah i don't think we
should send our you know every kind of
soldier that we have black white mexican
whatever it might be
over and fight i don't think we should
send anybody from america is that okay
oh well i don't know i think that's
racist uh next segment hey by the way
it's sexist literal credit.com tour dave
and i are on tour uh we'll be in tulsa
oklahoma on may 14th the show in
colorado springs sold out we're going to
add another show and then dave you have
a show coming up i do uh uh hard for
funny bone next weekend and then go to
dave landau.com some illinois dates well
i think it's not that loud.com tour we
have updates on there too yes your dates
and the dates we do together but tulsa
oklahoma may 14th it's close to filling
up so if you want those tickets do it go
buy them right now all right here's
another thing that's happening today hey
let me ask you this all the crypto
people out there who always get my
attention when i'm just trying to get a
slurpee at quick trip to tell me what i
need to invest in
what's up do you feel safe with your
cryptocurrency today here's my thing is
i i i understand the concept behind
cryptocurrency now before we get mad
the primary driving
purpose for cryptocurrency is that it
can't be regulated that something can
sort of be you know be under the radar
well that's not a thing anymore yeah and
i know you'll say well only the ones
that are on these markets so just just
stop look the only cryptocurrencies that
will be available will be the ones that
you use to maybe buy bombs in the dark
web at some point and by the way most
people aren't actually spending money
with cryptocurrency this is just my
little summary here they're usually
actually making it part of a diversified
portfolio and looking at how much it's
increased and worth and it's basically
another another form of a stock in
equity that's what it is you're trading
it like a commodity and it's a
speculative market my point here is
everyone said cryptocurrency man acting
like it was a digital version of gold
that the government couldn't touch
well we know today because of biden's
executive order that's no longer the
case and we saw it with trudeau but
here's the thing that you may not know
and the media lied to you about this
isn't new so you're reading about this
this morning former vice president biden
is going to sign an executive order
today
uh in a uh whole of government quote
push to regulate crypto currencies uh
now of course just to give you account
40 million um american adults traded
cryptos last year so good
there's a chance that a good quite many
of you have yeah 40 million so that's 40
that's 40 million more than uh colbert
viewers
his is almost less than all of that
uh
now here's how he framed it though he's
going to sign this today this executive
order and it's framed as though the
orders written
as a response to russian aggression let
me read you what they're saying
spoiler not true
so it reads cryptocurrencies may
undercut u.s sanctions and efforts to
fight money laundering
a senior administration official said
and by the way we can always just
replace that with um
liar
concerns have been heightened as the u.s
has leveled sanctions on russia in
response to its invasion of ukraine uh
here's the thing this has been in the
works for a very very long time they
just want you they just need to use this
war
for your buy-in yeah this is cover when
people talk about the war machine okay
after 9 11 i think some people needed
some ass kickings i don't think that
iraq was well advised just to be clear
but i do think there's an appropriate
time for but when people talk about the
war machine what they're talking about
is using a war to ram through whether it
could be economic policies whether it
could be other domestic policy that have
nothing to do with that war like
cryptocurrency so november 2021 there
was a report from the president's
working group on financial markets you
can uh see the references at
lightroom.com
and it shows you you have it right here
from the department of uh treasury
that's the reference we have that shows
us in the works long before the invasion
uh the order will help this is what they
said protect u.s and global financial
stability right that's what they're
saying now about russia here's the truth
it's actually about increasing revenue
from digital assets by the way you can
actually where am i getting that from in
the bill they said it was about
increasing revenue from digital assets
here's a quote the law will require
brokers aka cryptocurrency exchanges to
notify the irs directly of crypto
transactions that's november 2021 it has
nothing to do with russia and ukraine
this is a long time coming i told you
guys about it if you believe it has
anything to do with putin
you're you probably watched joyride
right well and look at the trudeau
example right he he had the emergencies
act uh they're gonna say the shoe policy
well no no that's i mean he does that
too but yeah he loves black folks it's
wednesday that's his cryptocurrency
dora's blackface so they had an
emergencies act they shut down gofundme
and then they seized and froze assets
essentially for some of these people
that they were trying to kick out or
punish for being protesters or leading
the protests and then they actually
seized some of their crypto wallets as
well now there's some issues with that
you can you can have a decentralized
wallet so they are only using this as a
cover to do things like that because you
said they want to maintain you know like
they want to get revenue from it too
they also want to maintain dominance
right exactly they want to launch i read
through this entire thing they want to
launch their own cryptocurrency that is
a reflection on the us dollar right it's
essentially just a virtual dollar this
is why i don't even understand it
anymore if the government wants to
launch their own cryptocurrency then
what is cryptocurrency i thought the
whole point was to evade the government
it's a threat to the governments right
and that's what everybody knows how is
the government going to release a
cryptocurrency it makes no sense well
they can do it well they're just going
to
steal it and then take all the money
they want and then go hey it's worth a
dollar now and you're screwed yeah well
you mean do what the government does and
probably find anybody who's made
millions and millions and millions off
of crypto and go back in your taxes
right oh boy there's some guy illegally
streaming this from his basement right
now which by the way chet you don't need
to do it's already free
check the multi-millionaire from
cryptocurrency we know we're onto you
cash out all your crypto change your
money to chas or name
both
autonomous chat this is just the issue
that
this is the problem with trying well
this is the problem with war the problem
with war when you're talking is it's
used to obfuscate so much yeah i mean
we're still sort of peeling back the
layers with iraq
right there were a lot of people who
supported going into iraq and then
afterwards oh
probably not because we didn't have all
the information that we needed it's fine
to change your mind based on new
information not to change your
principles that's a key that's a key
difference that i think a lot of people
need to make you can change your mind
based on new information not change your
opinion and your principles
that was my issue i was with mitt romney
where mitt romney said i'm pro-life now
he didn't really have a good enough
reason because he was already a mormon
and of course most mormons are pro-life
and then he said i'm pro-life but i
wasn't before well what changed that's
changing a principle changing your mind
for example strategically on iraq
because you see how the war was carried
out and you see the fallout that's not
changing your principle you still
believe in the principle of life liberty
pursuit of happiness you're just saying
well that didn't really serve those
principles yeah well and right now the
public only has so much bandwidth so
many things that we can care about and
so we've seen kovid pretty much
disappear from the news i don't know the
last time that i've actually seen
something that's not a thing covid right
now right everything you see right now
is russia ukraine and president biden
biden is doing a fantastic job you don't
see anything about this this is the time
when you have to be very very careful
because the administration and the
politicians know
nobody is watching the store and they
can do things that you may not agree
with and then it's too late they can go
in they can rob the store provided it's
under 999 well that's
no no it's congress so it's 999 million
but once the queen gets ivermectin
allegedly you kind of have to kind of
got to stop doing what you're doing and
be like okay
uh red-handed well i don't think people
really cared because that's the least
offensive thing coursing through the
queen's blood well that's true forcing
her blue blood right the the actual
horse blood in her is worse than me
the gene therapy and by that i mean uh
her brother slash father's jeans that
course through her veins
trying to escape her fingertips is why
she's always doing this i don't know how
they live so long it's it's really well
i think that might be the secret to a
long long life granted it's a terrible
painting
horrible existence yes
i found the it's the fountain of youth
oh what's that well having sex with your
sibling yes it's a trade-off someone
killed me it's like the old monkey paw i
wished for everlasting life and then i
had to do unspeakable things i've heard
the screams from hell since i was a girl
yes they get louder every day can you
hear them now do you hear the screams of
hell ringing they're always ringing i
sat on my back nipples and it hurts
oh that's disgusting
that's why i never remove this jacket it
looks like i'm from a puppy mill
i don't need those flippers for scuba
diving i've brought my own that's i made
them in the womb what's that there again
there's a good lord givethan he taketh
away he did giveth i've set all human
aquatic speed records
she just can go pearl diving for 19
minutes yeah that's why she has all
those necklaces yeah
she found all the jewels
in pirate's treasure yeah
i found the heart of the ocean yes
i drug up the treasure chest with my
teeth
i'm insanely strong
just comes out of the water with a knife
in her mouth like a pirate
all right may i have a bedpan for one of
my four anuses
that's more efficient
no look yeah i mean come on i don't have
enough time in the day
who can wipe this patch after the after
the third one it's just like having your
ears pierced
so
here's something else while we're
talking about the media and that's sort
of the theme today of the media rip
misrepresenting almost
this is a conversation i had at fox news
when i worked there i worked it for four
and a half years i remember having a
conversation with one of
one of the top
one of the top two people that thought
let's put it that way that way that
narrows it down top person at fox news
was it the fat one
no it wasn't you think of the the rapey
one yeah could have been no no idea it
wasn't raj so i had a conversation where
they said yeah you know if mitt romney
wins so that's going to be bad for uh
it's going to be bad for business i said
what do you mean well you know being the
opposition party i said it doesn't
matter who wins
you have the entire entertainment uh
entertainment media industrial complex
that's the problem
that's the enemy the people who are
lying who are pulling the wool over the
eyes of the american people so
biden's not really a very fun adversary
the former vice president because he's
an idiot so it's almost not fair at
least barack obama was cunning he was
smart enough you know with donald trump
it was fun for the left because he was
aggressive he was bombastic but but it's
it's it's it's like spanking a puppy
people feel bad for them even if they
don't like maybe it's a really bad puppy
that being said
the media is really that's my problem
this this is what i've always been
passionate about is the corruption is
the dishonesty and the people who
control information by the way there's
nothing more important right now
probably
to the free world than the free flow of
information because it's controlled by
about five companies
and that's why you're seeing everyone on
the same page so
here's something that happened uh uh
this week and thank god uh governor
desantis shut it down um florida bill
h1557 or as you may know it the don't
say gay bill which by the way appears
nowhere in the bill cryptocurrency
appears in the november 20th 21st bill
yeah yeah yeah don't say gay appears
nowhere in this bill that being said uh
it uh of course was portrayed this way
and it was trending all over twitter in
the media the don't say gay bill well
today florida lawmakers passed what
opponents have called the don't say gay
bill the measure would limit classroom
lessons on sexual orientation and gender
identity among young children the aclu
says 15 other states are considering
bills thank god also address lgbtq plus
issues in school florida's so-called
don't say gay bill is one step closer to
becoming law you called it this as it
makes its way to governor ron desantis's
desk the controversial legislation says
that schools cannot encourage classroom
discussion about sexual orientation or
gender identity there's an epidemic of
lgbtq kids hurting themselves here don't
take away their reason not to
kindergarten those basic values by
advancing legislation that is designed
to target and attack the kids who need
the support support the most uh kids
from uh the lgbtqi plus uh community
well first of all let me address a
couple things first they're not the
people who need the help the most
not necessarily
some of them need help sure but let's
just call it a wash all kids need help
second we're supposed to believe that
kids in the third grade kindergarten
through the third grade are hanging
themselves from a slipknot on the
ceiling fan because they can't take a
dump in the bathroom of their choice
that's why we need this spell also can
you just the so called don't say gay
bill oh so that's what we're doing now
you can just make up whatever you want
and say so called if you are the one who
so called it so i can say this
so-called former vice president riddled
with dementia and or parkinson's
so-called right
so it has been called
i think that works out really well by
the way the other guy who was saying in
the meeting he said these people are
hurting themselves and don't take away
the reason not to it's like oh oh so you
care about kids i care about kids
hurting themselves which is why you
don't shut down schools and drive up
suicide rates and isolate kids in
dangerous situations sometimes you don't
do that were you at that protest as well
making sure schools could reopen
kids can't look off their phone for two
seconds being locked in their room for
two years being scared to do anything or
make a choice themselves i don't think
that hurt anybody no i'm sure that it's
because they're reading harry potter
books and harry potter still has his
penis that's why they're hurting look
it's like easy to solve don't teach
little kids about sexual orientation and
give them some safety scissors five to
eight years old can we say don't stay
don't uh say straight
like why don't we just not teach
sexuality to anybody that age well and
that's why let's let them be kids is
that crazy yeah could you let a child at
least hit 11 before they realize the
penis is the bane of their existence and
ruin their life yes before they
eliminate their ability to climax for
the rest of their life before the age of
sexual consent i'm just saying like it's
just as a guy i'd just let him be happy
for ten years it goes away if my kid
asks for a toaster shoe for breakfast
the answer is no can you imagine what
i'm going to say if he asks for an
estrogen pellet
and i'm i don't want my penis just just
eat your broccoli
i don't like broccoli either fine just
cut off your penis
these kids are so clever by the way uh
mark hamill even uh uh tweeted out
lots of them
really sticking it to the man uh you
watch some of the recent star wars yeah
well that's also he also unfortunately
tweeted out this picture which just
seems like you know this is what we're
talking about it's not appropriate
ruining a children's for it's disney
disney come on
suck it you will yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no okay is that the dark side no it's
just him they're role-playing
the point is they're consenting adults
it's totally what yoda and luke do in
their own bedroom is their own business
well fine it is part of the jedi
training yes
why do you think he lives alone on the
planet he calls it
that's why i was raising the x-wing did
you know like he wasn't that far from it
it wasn't no contact it was
yeah he's court-ordered to be on that
planet yes you can't be around anybody
like we have to go find
a hundred galaxies
with children he's got an ankle where's
luke he didn't find yoda on the woods
planet did he yoda just comes out with
those giant office space glasses and
luke just comes back really quiet
oh dessert what
so the bill is actually called parental
rights and education okay that's what
the bill is called the media leaves out
key details in this bill not only does
it not have nowhere in the bill does it
say don't say gay right okay this isn't
the lovely bones there are no rules
except don't say gay that's another rule
no this that doesn't appear anywhere in
the bill let me read you what the bill
is about classroom instruction by school
personnel or third parties on sexual
orientation or gender identity may not
occur in kindergarten through grade
three or in a matter that is not age
appropriate or developed mentally
appropriate hey that bill almost seems
entirely appropriate
and by the way it wouldn't this wouldn't
even be necessary if you weren't having
drag queen story hour for kids with by
the way multiple serial pedophiles we've
covered that many times you can't find
it on youtube go on mug club search
stephen crowder drag queen story time
i'm sorry but you are also welcome and
thank you governor desantis for
addressing this for um the absolute
tomfoolery that it is
in education what critics call the don't
say gay bill is on the senate does it
say that in the bill that you support
does it say that in the bill i'm asking
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it doesn't matter what
critics say it says it bans classroom
instruction on sexual identity and
gender orientation for who
for for grades pre-k through three so
five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-olds and um
the idea that you wouldn't be honest
about that and tell people what it
actually says it's why people don't
trust people like you because
narratives and so we just abuse you of
those narratives
and we're going to make sure that
parents are able to send their kid to
kindergarten without having some of this
stuff injected into their school
curriculum
i would like them to stop using the word
disabuse
just start abusing them
inject it also didn't help no it also
didn't help also he's my president i
hope everyone knows that yeah i would
love to see him run uh a couple of
things here you know what can we do a
little exercise really quickly
a lot of kids on college campuses are
not even learning the socratic method
anymore so they're learning critical
race theory they're learning modern
gender theory socratic method how many
times we've done it changed my mind and
we've asked them are you aware of this
credit method
no response okay so
all right
sexual orientation and gender identity
okay of course the left wants to teach
this to children
ages kindergarten through the third
grade all right
why
let me ask you this okay
that means we need to make people aware
of sexual orientation
what is that what is sexual orientation
sexual orientation determines
your sex and which member of sex you're
attracted to i sexually attracted to i
can't even say it without using the word
sex both sex meaning gender the actual
word sex and sex meaning sexual activity
your sex s-e-x-e and
sexual attraction so well maybe that's
inappropriate because we're talking
about sex with kids gender identity well
what does that mean
what is gender identity it's determining
whether you are what
male or female well why does that matter
because it matters to identify as one or
the other for all sexual activity for
the remainder of your life so we want to
teach children not only will not only
teach them about these
sexually charged issues but also as you
see legislatively give them permission
to alter permanently
their sexual capabilities i know you say
gender and sex are separate but guess
what it's still actually when you change
your gender it affects your sexual
function we want to teach children about
this before they've even reached the age
of sexual consent
and you wonder why parents are telling
you to screw off in record numbers right
and we also combine this with what some
of the courts or at least some of the
politicians want to do they want to make
it to where parents can't prevent their
children from getting these puberty
blockers and things like that they want
to make it to where parents can't
homeschool right they want to take away
all this control and by the way i don't
even think this bill goes far enough
look you're telling me that a
nine-year-old should be having these
conversations i remember giving third
grade
eight four fourth grade i'm going to
fourth grade oh he's saying just like
third grade right no i'm saying at sixth
grade they had the sex talk with us in
school i remember because we all made
jokes because we're sixth grade boys
right they're just giving us kind of a
basic conversation
that was even something that felt like
okay maybe that's on the line but that's
at least closer but come on they're not
supposed to be thinking about this
anyway and it's not that you want to
make it okay for somebody who's feeling
that way you want to brainwash them
because we've heard you say it's okay to
explore you tell a six year
seven-year-old it's okay to explore and
they're they don't really even know who
they are yet and then they go down these
pads and they're like oh well they said
it's okay to go out and explore this
stuff it's totally fine
how in the world do you expect let me
tell you this i had the sex talk when i
was like three or four but my parents
wanted to give me the sex talk so i
understood it when i was young precisely
because they didn't want me to learn it
in the quebec public educational system
exactly you shouldn't be learning it
from a stranger certainly not before the
age of sexual we're not talking remember
how it started with we need sex ed in
schools and then what happened is you
would have some christians saying like
well actually okay we see this being a
slippery slope because this is something
where maybe you could be teaching our
teenagers something that we don't
necessarily want them to learn sexually
then it became we're going to teach them
sex edge sex ed in a very broad sense
which included
all kinds of sex acts at that point that
border even on no longer actually sex
because there's no capability to
reproduce nor even a partner who's
capable of reproducing with you and then
they want to have basically a sex
education including
homosexuality and gender identity
with six-year-olds
well yeah and even in sixth grade like
you said the maturity level isn't there
i died laughing when our gym teacher
rolled a condom onto a banana
with his mouth yes
because you'd seen him do it dressed as
yoda well no that really was just a
slideshow of stds is all it was it was
like and this is syphilis and gonorrhea
if you don't get it treated and you're
like what what it was just endless but
the reason why they want to do it this
young is very very simple
kids will believe anything
that's it yeah so if you can jam this
into their throat as being that's
terrible that was a terrible i really
did worse than desantis's injection yes
it is
but it is true if you can tell them at a
young age where they're able to be
susceptible to any information you give
them because they trust you that's how
they get the information into a kid and
that's how they can complete a narrative
that's the reality and then it's normal
it's everything that we want to push the
aaip the plus everything that we want to
say not just today but stuff that we
come up with later it's all normal sex
education shouldn't be allowed in an
elementary school
no i don't think that's a crazy thought
no i don't think i thought we were
trying to and if you and if your parents
want to talk about it too that's that's
different i learned when i was like i
said when i was a kid i learned what
something was because i saw a video and
i thought it was an ice cream cone
seriously and then like later on didn't
help that you saw that video in the back
of an ice cream truck well it's true
well i saw me on video after
but i remember like my
learning about sex ed then my mom showed
us a video which was you know a sperm
with a baseball cap and it didn't help
and then after that we watched
philadelphia
i just i didn't like any of it no it all
just seemed like it would kill you yeah
no that's what they showed us a bunch of
slides with us stds and i went home and
said what'd you do i'm like well i
showed us slides of jfk today yeah yeah
no one would let why would you let it go
to that
like certainly the itching itself like i
get that it can happen
with it can happen in one act with the
wrong partner but letting it progress to
the point right where you look like the
royal family well i mean there's an
elephant in the room but there's a point
where it's like how long did you ignore
this for yes for two years you're like
i'm fine yeah i'm good it'll get better
nothing in the room your member doesn't
have to look like the elephant man yeah
meanwhile every time you take a step
you're just crying yeah you just hear a
crunch
[Music]
i'm a human
just a lot of dandruff hey speaking of
which uh you know i was gonna admonish
you for that point but we can't because
i need to be admonish now let me explain
this to you yes
i said something and by the way i want
you to comment below and admonish me
so this is because we want to be as
transparent as possible when i make
mistakes
i said something yesterday that was so
incredibly dumb
that as soon as the show ended i turned
to jail and said i can't believe i said
that
that was moronic yes it was staring me
right in the face and for some reason i
missed it it wasn't the cello thing
either no it wasn't the cello thing
i'm still wrong about that
i'm not so yesterday we were talking
about cain velasquez uh and you know
free kane and the guy who tried to shoot
the the pedophile who molested his child
okay so then i decided to try and extend
an olive branch to people of all
different walks of life discussing
different religions
and pedophilia i made this dumb
statement just yesterday on mug club any
of the actual mainstream religions
across the globe whether it's hinduism
whether it's taoism whether it's
buddhism whether it's islam okay
i don't know of any religion
that has anything
but disdain i know some religions don't
have hate at all but disdain
for pedophiles
okay
see if you can get worse my producers
quickly pointed out and i had already
recognized it so at this point it was
like was just brow beating me yeah that
of course i got this incorrect because
i mean muhammad had a six-year-old child
bride oh mohammed had a six-year-old
child bride
and so
hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait
but then i realized it's not really fair
of you to admonish me it's not because
he only consummated when she was nine
but wow we really missed that
i guess we're splitting hairs at that
point i mean a little bit yeah maybe
michael bay movie pretty quick
he waited 30 percent longer yeah she'd
been alive only made love to her size
how long do they live though well who
knows 15. well depends are you
accounting for the psychological trauma
oh no hey i mean i i'm not saying i'm
for it right yeah i just was curious if
it was like king tut at 13 right or if
it was like 45 no he was old and she
wasn't six
yeah yeah
i'm not saying six is okay in any point
even if he's nine right it's still bad
it's still weird yeah it still shouldn't
be taught i just didn't know if we had
an age yeah i don't think we should have
muhammad sex class no no well that would
just be abuse yeah i well i wouldn't i'm
not gonna say it would just be don't
commit these felonies you guys do you
i'm fine with it yeah don't don't don't
get mad at me yeah yeah i'm very uh
afraid of your peace it's always funny
too when people say well aisha actually
really she adored and she loved muhammad
you ever hear of stockholm syndrome
she didn't have a choice it could be
called god muhammad said i mean at the
time they didn't stockholm was around
the thing i guess in a psychology book
she that's the point that's the problem
she didn't know what to call it it was
just called kidnapping yes
spoils of war which he all well that's
basically what he did there and he also
did that
uh
all right so there we go i've been
admonished
as you should be okay let's move on here
to uh something that i also wanted us
what's happening right now talking about
uh power to cut okay
power to turn up well that's
i drive a tesla yes yeah that's what
he's saying i'd be willing to pay 45
a gallon
i'm in the middle of a white on white
war who cares
let's talk about yemen um you know how
insignificant yemen is back in
i don't know it was in the 90s there was
an episode of friends when chandler was
trying to avoid janus this annoying
woman and he was like i can't uh be with
you because i'm
moving to yemen
that was the joke was he didn't even
know he just made up a country and then
he had to actually go to yemen so they
picked
the most insignificant country
inconsequential country to make a joke
about which used to be okay back then
but now we have to act like yemen is
equal and i'm not saying that the
conflict is not one that is riddled with
geo and corruption by the way yeah of
course corruption also uh she was a
jewish woman with a giant nose who had a
nasally laugh that's what she
well and dave you know that midnight
train going to anywhere it used to say
anywhere but yemen but they have true
yeah exactly i prefer his brother yeoman
yes
omen i prefer well yeah well
that was his middle middle name first
name damian damian damian yeoman that's
it damian newman yeah
and somebody where's yamin and cayman
right right yep all right make sure i
have this right raymond islands thank
you yeah
by the way yeah make sure you get that
right because cayman islands yehman
islands horrible yeah
yeah terrible very bad it's not the same
offshore account you can't even hide i
don't think that's how cryptic i hit all
my money in the yemen islands oh
you're gonna lose it you're gonna lose
everything that's bad was that oh it's a
typo oh boy you don't have anything left
it's all good it always gets the details
speaking of dollars
let's talk about something go with me
here for a second because this may sound
boring but i'm going to try and simplify
it so that
so easy that uh you know even cnn could
could understand it okay
a big fallout too with this war with
russia and ukraine there's a lot of it
that doesn't really affect you yeah
until we get to the point where there's
there are actual nukes being launched or
you know uh international missiles being
launched whatever type of international
weaponry you want to discuss that being
said there are things that affect you
right away especially as we're
discussing the economic sanctions with
russia and with uh ukraine
uh
the united states you know what it means
the reserve currency yeah can you
explain for people who don't know here
let me let me explain it to you really
quick um do you ever kind of wonder
why the united states can afford to take
out huge amounts of debt and why it's so
cheap for americans to buy foreign
products that's the short answer is
because of the status of the united
states dollar as the reserve currency
now what does that mean as of about 2020
uh 59 of central bank reserves around
the world are basically held in american
dollars what does that mean that means
that the american dollar dominates
finance across the globe not just the
united states that's why we are
effectively the world's only superpower
right now it's why sanctions coming from
the united states currently have teeth
and hurt
now
when the united states sanctions russia
economically
and this is something that joel and i
were talking about and this is what
we're discussing right now sanctioning
them economically it pushes them to use
what
someone else's currency oh in the arms
of another lover huh it pushes them into
the arms of another lover now who might
that be good thing i have some quotes
here i'll reference available at light
with credit.com biden's flexing of
american economic muscle will only
embolden russia and other u.s rivals
notably china
to deprive the united states of the very
power that makes sanctions so
devastating russia and china will
expedite initiatives to de-dollarize
their economies building alternative
financial institutions and structures
that protect themselves from the
sanctions so look let me give you let me
give you an update on what this means
for all of you okay because if this
happens where the united states loses
its reserve currency status yeah it will
destroy life as you know it and as
christians that's where you're gonna
have to start finding comfort by god's
definition not comfort by your
definition but it will destroy
your life as you know it not saying
you're going to die what i'm going to
say is everything that you know how you
purchase things the kinds of life the
kinds of life luxuries that you can
enjoy
gone in a flash you're going to have to
learn how to live differently
last week i think was it last week that
we reported uh visa mastercard visa
mastercard in a slew of other companies
but this one specifically on the
financial side they pulled out of russia
and basically what that did is that
pushed russia into the arms of china
again with union well how so oh union
pay the chinese yes exactly it's state
owned oh well yes chinese state owned
the payment system so sort of free so we
think like hey great we're pressure and
by the way they'll also still accept
diners club don't know why weird
they're the last place on the planet
that has members in soviet russia we
only accept union pay we also take
diners club it doesn't make sense to me
just slide it across long table yeah i
like it yes i'm in a i like the logo
that has not been updated since 1974.
it looks like surfer it looks like a
dogtown z-boys t-shirt yes
um
here's the thing first off this doesn't
this also doesn't punish putin
you think putin's paying with mastercard
he's paying with a glare
what do you think the last time somebody
walked up to him with a check come on
he's just sitting in an atm like son of
a [ __ ] yeah exactly i've used every
card my wife oh no
i'm overdraft oh go discover still works
fine
yes oh hey good oh they can take all the
help i can give exactly
so this is and this is obviously we know
about this okay russia and china we've
talked about this russia and china
should not be allies yeah they should
hate each other because russia now is
vehemently anti-communist at least
that's what putin says but we've seen
them now creating these alliances we
talked about the wheat embargo yeah
that's a big deal a ton of it there
right selling a ton of oil right
but it's not just russia and china and
this is something else that maybe you
could bring yeah there are other people
that we want to keep on our side what
kind of other people i really don't know
we did an ion segment for these people
for a long time but right now we really
want you to be afraid i'm foreshadowing
india also has the same fear that the
united states might use similar kind of
crippling economic sanctions to against
them and you might go well look that's
never going to happen remember when
trump went over there and he was
received in their qriket stadiums with
like a hundred thousand people or
something like that or even more
hugely popular over there and china is
not necessarily naturally going to align
itself with india they don't just like
russia right but the biden
administration is actually considering
sanctions on india right now for a
purchase yeah that they made in 2018
when they bought some stuff they weren't
supposed to buy crypto it was probably
with crypto yeah
yeah that's exactly right kidding me no
and here's the thing yeah so india
generally hates china right and vice
versa you know well the chinese hate
everything well that's true they don't
even hate other asians because they're
not asian enough according to the
chinese and japanese have done to each
other i'm not saying that i don't like
the chinese i'm saying the chinese don't
like non-chinese the chinese don't like
the chinese that's true well they're not
sort of like they're french
not good to their people the french
don't like the french that's why when
you get down to the people who no one
likes the french and france just make
fun of the french from quebec and the
french from quebec just make another
french from france it's just silly
that is silly it's so irrelevant yeah
you guys are silly they're just just
each other's good wine parade whipping
post so india hates china so much to
give you some historical context they
actually bought a missile defense system
from india bought that bought this from
russia largely to protect
against china ah right yeah to protect
against china india bought a missile
defense system this should this is a
good good example this should be a
really easy opportunity it's a layup
when we're talking about international
dece you know uh destabilization
to make india an ally yeah exactly and
just if people are out there saying look
india is never going to do anything like
this just remember what happened in war
one i've said it before russia and
germany germany pretty much destroyed
russia and led to the revolution that
they had in their country right and then
in world war ii they signed a
non-aggression pact before that one
worked like a charm yeah exactly right
up until somebody was aggressive but
when countries see an opportunity all of
a sudden things become a little bit more
clear russia says you know what maybe we
don't like china a whole lot right now
but if we ally with them we can form
this dominance over here we'll deal with
it down the road them kind of
overpowering us same thing with india
did you mean to say ally or a line but
you mixed the two did i say alive yeah
ah well and i thought you were talking
about mine
admonish him i think that might be a
proper usage of that word but maybe not
i disagree
no uh the appropriate use of that word
and muhammad didn't have sex with a
six-year-old go on gerald cello over
here talking about india um yeah well
we'll be playing the violin correctly
over here yeah but you're talking about
countries that have been warring
essentially over the cashmere region
right and they they basically
well it's not the sweaters dave
they wouldn't be natural allies but when
you see an opportunity and you have the
threat and that's what the biden
administration is and just to be clear
china right now and when i say china
just to be clear unless you try and say
that in case you're trying to say that
this is racist we empathize
deeply with the chinese people
which is why i have
unbelievable hatred for the communist
chinese government so when i say china
what i really mean are the chai comes
now
uh i think if i clarify everything we
say is
right i know it really is of course we
don't have an issue with chinese people
it's a terrible government yeah
fantastic food
same with here here american chinese
food i think russians did a lot for
detroit hockey yep they absolutely did
defend the people
so china who runs the show it's a bit of
a dick
i couldn't couldn't agree more now china
though they are they're basically hoping
praying and wishing and hoping that the
united states sanctions china why so
they can swoop in so where am i getting
this from sunday foreign minister wang
yi i hope i'm pronouncing it correctly i
don't care said uh china
india should be partners rather than
adverse hold on i'm sorry can you read
that in the appropriate
china india should be no no no no no no
no china and india should be partners
right on adversaries if your name is
wang do you really care if somebody
mispronounces it yeah
please excuse me no no it's pronounced
dick hey wang yeah you're like excuse me
it's it's wang yes i come from a long
line of wings it's wang [ __ ] many wings
pink oh well it just seems like you're
putting that on don't tell me what my
name is it's my cousin yang wow
say my name say my name my name it
sounds like penis so
wang yao is four inches biggest man in
china
um now also this is something else we
need to recognize that india is a major
partner to the united states right yeah
um and uh they now need to
well look they need a hedge yes they are
a hedge fund against china in the
pacific right and china is trying to
take over as much as they can and we
have this kind of group of four
countries called the quad india is a
part of that currently right now united
states japan and australia right does
austral australia does a ton of trade
with china do they look like a
non-authoritarian regime right now do
they look like they're leaning towards
western democracy or do they look like
they're leaning towards chinese
authoritarian right right this is a
problem because if india goes that's two
we talk about this in a second but we
said it yesterday it's 2.9 billion
people combined with those three
countries and if australia joins it's
u.s and japan and that's it over there
so put it this way right you're saying
okay no more oil coming to the united
states from russia okay all right what's
going to happen well this oil is going
to be offloaded somewhere so you're
going to increase trading between russia
china and now india may want to get in
on that action so if they create an
alliance which really should never never
happened never have happened no this
nowhere in nature would india russia and
china
become bedfellows it's only through the
monumental screw-ups of european and
american foreign policy so now you've
created a scenario where 2.9 billion
people that's almost half of population
earth
could decide to no longer
recognize the united states as reserve
currency and what does that mean well
guess what it means that our sanctions
no longer have teeth and what does it
mean for you specifically well you think
inflation is bad now you're talking
about unbelievable inflation if the
united states uh dollars not the reserve
currency you're talking about
unbelievably high interest rates so we
just look at that you say okay a credit
card no no no look increase inflation do
you want to buy a gallon of milk we're
not just talking about gas
we're talking about everything and we're
also talking about devaluing your dollar
do you want to send your kids to a
private school
do you want to be able to take your kids
to six flags do you want to be able to
buy a candy bar
do you do you know whatever it is we're
talking about inflation the likes of
which you've never seen interest rates
do you want to buy a home well that's
almost out of reach for many middle
class americans now and that's not
because of the market that's because of
too big to fail companies snatching up
uh you know single-family homes right
now like blackrock oh it's crazy so high
interest rates you want to buy it buy a
home you want to want to buy a car the
tesla you're supposed to go on tesla
you're supposed to buy come on wow
there's 15 gas for the rest of the
police
well you can both get a tesla that's the
price of a home right yeah exactly at
this point our debts by the way can be
called in yeah so what does that do that
that weakens the the dollar
internationally it basically would
weaken the amer the american
standing right the standing of the
united states right now you have not
experienced a world you right now
watching you have not experienced a
world where the united states is
anything other than the sole economic
and global super superpower and
up until recently
i believed that we were usually on the
right side of history that's my biggest
concern that's my biggest concern with
this administration right now is we
could i hate to say it i love this i
love this country i will fight to defend
this country that's why i moved here
from that shitty country known as canada
but
as i see this international conflict
unfolding i do worry that maybe with the
people at the helm
we may not be on the right side of
history it may be that point in time
where people look back and go america
was really wrong on that one
that's what's scary to me and you've
never lived in a world where the united
states is not the sole global superpower
and unlike do you know what global
superpowers looked like before the
united states
take look at the english empire
look at the ottomans look at the turks
look at the romans
they never fought a war for someone else
to give them back their stuff yeah the
fact that canada exists
is proof that this is a an unbelievably
unique superpower
there's nothing they could do to stop us
we could take over mexico and be in the
drug business it's very lucrative yes
and by the way i think purdue is
actually doing that right now well
i mean
so if these three countries get together
and it seems like they are moving that
way
we don't need to go to war with the
military to already be at war and you're
making this point too at what point do
we say we are at war how are we not how
is this not war when you're funding
somebody to defend against an invasion
you're actually saying hey we need to
give them they'll stop it sending
aircrafts from poland which is happening
right now but they're like yeah but
we'll give you like billions of dollars
to buy some if you can find them right i
don't know how this is not war and by
the way think about this for a second
we're thinking about sanctions on india
for what for purchasing yeah missile
defense for purchasing missile defense
that's a good idea okay so we're
punishing them for uh what for for for
trading military equipment with the
didn't the united states do that with
ukraine didn't we sell them some [ __ ]
that could hurt people i think but you
know so we can do it but other countries
can't they're white pardon my ignorance
are we pretending we're not at war
are we still doing that is that
happening i'm serious i thought that was
official i don't i didn't get the memo
oh i don't know i still don't know if
it's okay to do blackface or not because
i know megan kelly just talked about it
on a show and she was fired but then
there's a sitting prime minister who's
done it like 900 times yes but megyn
kelly doesn't hurt a bunch of people
right
well she does with her stare oh that's
true it's like looking into the sun i
imagine it's hard
no i i don't know her personally no and
exactly but you know you can levitate
your next swing so my point here is
look you've had it so good for so long
so many americans that you feel as
though you are removed well let me ask
you this let's do it this way do you
feel removed right now could you talk
with someone
in ukraine
on i don't know instant chat on snapchat
could you whatever app discord can you
play a video game with them can you up
until recently i don't know how it works
but i'm sure you can probably still play
with whoever and russia can afford these
video game systems same thing with japan
same thing with taiwan right do you
really feel that disconnected or do you
understand that you are closer than ever
because war is going to be fought
through information and through economic
punishment so don't think of this as
happening in some far-off lane just like
that guy in call of duty can blow your
ass away guess what your dollar our
dollar can be blown away if we keep
screwing up and we've been screwing up
monumentally have you felt it at the gas
pump
have you felt it at the grocery store
have you felt it really in anything take
your pick right now you can point to
anything in this economy okay and you
could have pointed to it before russia
ukraine
and asked if it was better point to
anything think about employment no
gas prices no take anything
that exists economically in this country
or your creature comforts point to it
no it's not better and it can get a
whole lot worse if you understand what
can happen when 2.9 billion people
decide that the united states is the big
evil of the world and without firing a
shot
they make it so that you will be a
permanent class of renters you will
never own you will own nothing and you
will like it oh
i forgot though
that's kind of the goal isn't it you can
comment below youtube we have a lot to
talk about that there's no way we could
discuss here uh because it's a violation
not only of tick tock but of you so good
looking out for china and we're going to
play they don't make them like they used
to breakfast at tiffany's piss off
you